the Joe Rogan experience is Donald Trump
this is actually Donald Trump snapchat
and he put this this is these are these
guys right here this and it comes with
this [ __ ] music there's so many
knockouts and you ain't black his son
knows how to use the Internet Donald
Trump jr. they use him for all the wild
[ __ ] when they need to post something
really wild they go to that's [ __ ]
great
listen man they're playing dirty
everybody's playing dirty yeah everyone
the world's playing different they're
all pretending you someone who not lying
about this no one's gonna be honest it's
just about creating impressions and
memes and getting these short attention
span [ __ ] to hold on to a
narrative as hard as possible
Russia Russia gave Russia whatever it is
we ask people they're upset they don't
even know what happened that's ninety
percent of people out there man we live
in the and now it's gonna be even
weirder because everybody's gonna be so
stressed out because the economy's in
the [ __ ] yeah and it's not gonna get out
of there any quick anytime soon it's
gonna take some time and what's gonna
happen this is like is this gonna be
class war because because the people
that can afford to stay home mm-hmm yes
they want everyone to go out and get the
economy going like they're super rich
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] about people
dying they can stay in their mansions
there's that aspect of it there's also
the and those are the ones that I know I
don't think I'm looking at it correctly
in terms of like the actual danger of
the virus but then there's other people
that are like hey I don't want to lose
my business
why don't you restart the economy so I
could take a chance I'd rather take a
[ __ ] chance I'm losing everything
I'm 99.999999% sure I'm gonna [ __ ]
survive this right you know and I'm
gonna I'm gonna know what's coming I'm
gonna take a lot of vitamins like let me
do what I have to do and let's let's
quarantine the people that are in danger
let's quarantine old people let's keep
them away until it goes away yeah that's
really for
and and this is what we need to do this
is what needs to be done not lock the
whole [ __ ] country down and once they
do that man they don't want to undo that
I don't know when reason left the world
but in so many different aspects of the
world is that what it was Twitter I mean
with there's just no reason almost
anywhere well I think the reason is to
save lives it's just not it doesn't make
sense it doesn't work right because your
lives with everything do there's an
article that can't final this is true
there's an article that I was reading in
the Washington Examiner what one of
those is a weird newspaper and it's like
it's it's one of those ones like what it
is what kind of is this a biased like
what what is the bias of the Washington
Examiner but it's basically saying that
there's more people dead from suicide in
Northern California than the war from
coronavirus deaths during the during why
because people are fully in despair
they're losing everything to go and
bankrupt and they don't see any way out
of it well if it wasn't for Korean
baseball I would be [ __ ] blow my
[ __ ] head off
[Applause]